[Music]
game uhhuh
uhhuh uh uh-huh uhhuh kissy face kissy
face sent to your phone but I'm trying
to kiss your lips for real uh-huh uh-huh
red hearts red hearts that's what I'm on
yeah come get me something I can feel oh
oh oh don't you want me like I want you
baby don't you need me like I need you
now see tomorrow but tonight go crazy
all you got to do is just meet me at the
I uhhuh
[Music]
uhhuh uhh uh it's whatever it's whatever
it's what ever you like turn this OPP
into a club I'm talking drink dance
smoke freak party all night come on gum
gum what's up oh oh oh don't you ow me
like I want you baby don't you need me
like I Need You Now s tomorrow but
tonight go crazy all you got to do is
just meet me at the
I
I I it uh uh-huh uh uh-huh I it
I I it uh uh-huh uh-huh hey so now you
know the game are you ready cuz I'm
coming to get you get you get you hold
on hold on I'm on my
way yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm on my
way hold God hold R I'm on my way
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm on my
way don't you want me like I want you
baby don't you need me like I need you
now sleep tomorrow but tonight go crazy
all you got to do is just meet me
I
I I
CH I
I
IET
me
I just make me
hey gang I hope you enjoyed that flow
session to what I have to say is
probably one of my favorite bangers I've
heard in a very very long time that song
is an absolute Bop any who if you are
interested in getting a set of those pop
and flow poy that I was using in this
video you can do so and get a discount
uh when you use the promo code Drex
Factor 112020
4 at checkout over flowtoys.com once
again that is drexfactor
11224 that gets you 10% off the prop of
your choice so go check that out and
flow toys thank you so very much for
sponsoring this video and giving me an
excuse to go out and get my groove on
and play around with some cool
Trails I also have to just put out a big
thank you to the Friends of the channel
uh big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca
flow fests flow toys Pyar light toys and
all Troy for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all of these amazing
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the non-b
buus friend of the channel Becca Becken
thank you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission finally
this video and all the videos on my
channel would not be possible without my
amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you all so much
you all rock and if you enjoy the
content that I create and you'd like to
see more of it the best way to make that
happen is to go check out my patreon and
sign up at
patreon.com drexfactor poy there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards but better than that you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring po
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world so go check that out please and
thank you if you'd like to check out
more of these flow sessions that I've
done over the years I will go ahead and
leave a link to playlist of those videos
down in the description as well as up on
screen but for right now thank you so
much for watching make sure to get out
and flow yourself today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace